well NASA is one step closer to
completing a daring mission using an
unmanned spacecraft to collect pieces of
an asteroid it requires having a
spacecraft catch up to orbit and scrape
the asteroid surface then return those
samples to earth and now we're getting
new images of the target of that effort
Kris Van Cleave reports NASA unveiled
these new images of been you and
asteroid about the size of five football
fields in the focus of a roughly billion
dollar mission to collect samples from
its surface the SUV sized or Cyrus Rex
spacecraft was launched almost two years
ago and is now close enough to get a
look at the asteroid by December it will
begin a delicate dance with been new
steering close enough that its robotic
arm will reach out and touch the surface
to collect dust and gravel
it'll spend more than a year orbiting
the asteroid and at just the right
moment make its break back for Earth
bringing with it it's treasure trove of
otherworldly samples by 2023 it's
chock-full of what we believe is amino
acids some of the building blocks of
life
we think it's got a fair amount of water
and it's these kind of objects that
bombarded the earth after the earth was
created that we believe may have brought
the material so necessary to have
sparked life here on earth NASA believes
been who contains carbon that dates back
four billion years to the start of our
solar system the mission if successful
will bring back the largest collection
of space samples since the Apollo moon
rocks by going there bringing back a
sample that's the only time we'll know
for sure how this fits in our evolution
there is another reason Ben who has
NASA's attention it has a 1 in 2,700
chance of striking earth in September 21
35
that sounds remote but by astronomical
standards that's caused enough to pay
close attention next week a different
asteroid this one the size of an
Egyptian pyramid will blow by our planet
at 20,000 miles per hour passing a mere
3 million miles from Earth for CBS this
morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Washington